je voulais vous remercier de votre
présence bien sûr il vous revient de
présenter cet après midi le rapport
d'activité de votre institution pour
l'année 2020
en réalité c'est sans vous faire injure
c'est pas tout à fait le vo2 pas
complètement puisque vous avez pris vos
fonctions récemment au mode d'un contenu
récemment on m'a donc à l'automne
dernier je crois même le 14 octobre
dernier ce qui fait que c'est aussi le
rapport de votre part et ses soeurs dans
la maison
vous allez nous présenter votre activité
et notamment qui a été fortement
impactée par la crise sanitaire
donc cette période évidemment toute
particulière en particulier pour votre
mission concernant dupré latif de
liberté les prisons et talisman de santé
ils sont éducatif fermé laissant doit
rétention administratif ou bien sûr des
locaux de garde à vue
peut-être juste un petit mot que je
ferai de la commission sur les autres
stations qui ont été formulées sur le
fait que nous avons voté ici au sénat le
8 avril le texte le respect de la
dignité en détention je crois dire que
pouvoir vous dire sans une démentie par
personne d'ailleurs que nous l'avons
fait parce que faute pour le
gouvernement d'avoir pris l'initiative
avant puisque je rappelle que il avait
un délai pour le faire et que ce délai
n'a pas été respecté et que pour éviter
à une difficulté nous avons pris
l'initiative
donc on s'inscrit en fait dans une
logique j'allais presque dire non pas de
substitution mais en tous les cas de
deux réponses à apporter la dignité en
prison et de traiter ce sujet là qui
nous étaient chers
parce que le gouvernement lui-même ne
l'avait pas fait voilà les jeux sont
ainsi dit ce qui suit les délais
dentelle ça s'est passé mais je vais
vous laisser la parole tenant juste pour
vous dire que je sais parfaitement que
c'est là que les chaussons ça fait
plaisir de l'entendre
bien jouer c'est la parole valable pour
la présentation de votre rapport je vous
en prie allez-y mais d'abord nous avons
bonjour et merci aussi de m'accueillir
je sais que ça doit être un exercice
pour vous qui vient en plus du reste
parce que c'est un exercice assez disons
contre un contenu annuel en tout cas
mais moi je viens ici
après avoir relu avec beaucoup d'émotion
je dois le dire et de nostalgie votre
rapport formidable le rapport formidable
du sénat qui date d'il ya 20 ans prison
une humiliation pour la république et je
me dis c'est mon propos introductif
comment se fait-il que vingt ans plus
tard on en soit toujours là c est
proprement incroyable et je pense que
malheureusement on s'est tous plus ou
moins habitués à cette humiliation et au
fait que les gens les détenus notamment
vivent actuellement dans les maisons
d'arrêt à trois par cellule car comme
vous le savez la population carcérale a
fortement remonté depuis les depuis
septembre dernier et je peux vous dire
que avant j'étais journaliste j'ai écrit
je ne sais combien de fois dans ma vie
ces hommes et ces femmes enfin sur
surtout des hommes vivent à 3 dans neuf
mètres carrés c'est faux ils vivent à 3
maintenant qu'on m'a ouvert les portes
des cellules
ils vivent à droite dans 4,2 mètres
carrés quart de ses neuf mètres carrés
il faut retrancher l'emprise des deux
lits superposés du matelas au sol qui a
beau être poussée contre le mur tient un
peu de place la petite a pour manger et
le coin toilette
c'est une image proprement effarante de
voir ça
c'est parce que surtout en ce moment en
ces temps de kobe d'où l'on sait que ces
23 heures sur 24 en cellule et je sais
pas lequel d'entre nous mais ça je crois
vous l'avoir déjà dit lequel d'entre
nous accepterait d'être surveillants
personnel pénitentiaire dans ces
conditions ça n'est plus possible il
faut qu'on en termine avec la
surpopulation d'une manière ou d'une
autre on nous parle de construction de
prisons
je pense que il ya eu un effort fait par
le gouvernement pressé fin je garde des
sceaux précédent plus tôt la garde des
sceaux pour vider les prisons à cause du
coc vide
et puis on a laissé le flux remontée de
plus belle et les les sorties il ya trop
d'entrée par cette sortie quelque chose
ne va pas et je pense que on devrait
tous interrogés sur ce qui s'est passé
dans nos têtes pour que qu'on en arrive
là qu'on en arrive à s'habituer à cet
état de fait et c'est pas comme ça que
que qu'on marche vers plus de
réinsertion des détenus et comme vous le
savez aussi bien que moi donc cette
année c'est vrai qu'elle a été assez
bouleversé parce qu'il ya une vacance de
trois mois de postes après adeline hazan
qui avait continué les visites et
d'ailleurs je lui rends un hommage
chaleureux et amical parce que elle a
fait un travail incroyable et j'espère
que l'ue ferait honneur pour la suite
dès que je suis arrivé on a repris les
visites
évidemment pendant les trois mois où
elle n'était pas là vous savez même ça
fait vingt-quatre mois 4 mois de visites
parce que quand ya pas de contrôleur on
ne peut pas ordonner de visites dans les
lieux de privation de liberté dont on
les a reprises c'est là que j'ai j'ai
j'ai pu enfin connaître de l'intérieur
ces lieux que je connaissais pas mal
quand même mais pas du tout de la façon
dont on les contrôle aujourd'hui ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que je vais vous
parler d'abord d'une préoccupation
vraiment qu'ils me la mine c'est celle
des enfants et des adolescents placés en
centres éducatifs fermés ou dans les les
les quartiers mineurs des prisons ou des
établissements pour mineurs parce que à
cela un qui devrait qui sont des
cabossés de la vie parce que comme vous
le savez d'après les études tu de la
moitié sorte de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ont été abandonnées ont été
ballotté de foyer de la jeunesse en
foyer de l'enfance en famille d'accueil
et j'aimerais qu'on leur accorde plus
d'attention c'est j'ai remarqué que aux
deux bouts de la vie les plus vieux on
l'a remarqué ça nous a sauté aux yeux
en ces temps de covile dans les ehpad
les plus âgés et les plus jeunes d'entre
nous donc chaque bout de la vie sont pas
les mieux protégés par la société ces
dames ainsi je peux dire ces adolescents
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en voir donc dans
des centres éducatifs fermés j'ai eu la
chance surtout de rencontrer d'aller
dans un centre éducatif qui marchait
mais du feu de dieu
c'est à dire avec une équipe pérenne
solide des gens qui étaient là depuis
dix ans avec un une institutrice une
prof qui étaient là tous les jours un
psychologue et franchement ce centre
éducatif fermé
il donnait envie y donner envie de
prendre modèle sur lui je les dis à
charlotte caubel la directrice de la pjj
qui a beaucoup de mal parce que on a
beaucoup de mal à recruter des
éducateurs vous lirez dans le rapport où
l'avez peut-être déjà lu on a beaucoup
de mal à recruter des équipes
d'éducateurs solide formée et formé à un
public difficile certes mais qui est
notre avenir à tous sont c'est la
jeunesse est l'avenir de notre société
cela comme les autres sont nos enfants
or ça va peut-être vous faire rire jaune
mais j'ai vu l'équipe du contrôle a
rencontré à contrôler un autre centre
éducatif fermé en revanche vous ça
marchait pas tellement bien et où il y
avait apparemment des difficultés
terribles de recrutement au point que
deux tenant sied de boîte de nuit qui
avait fermé à cause du coc vide s'était
dit bah tiens on va faire du social et
on va se présenter comme éducateur dans
un centre éducatif fermé ils ont été
aussitôt embauché puisqu'on banquet de
monde à ce sont des gens qui n'ont à
peine un gamin les provoquer ce qui est
un peu le fait de tous les gamins mais
en particulier de cela que boom
l'adolescent prenez une baffe en retour
ou une énorme engueulades où ça a
dégénéré en bagarre enfin bon vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et je trouve que
tous autant qu'on est on devrait ça
éviterait d'ailleurs que les prisons se
remplissent certainement on devrait
porter une attention énorme à à ces
enfants et ces adolescents dans les
centres éducatifs fermés c'est que le
gouvernement a pour projet d'en
construire 20 autres je crois que son
attention devrait se porter sur les sur
les conditions dans le recrutement des
des éducateurs et des équipes qui
forment
les formes ccc centre éducatif dans
celui que j'ai visitées il y avait par
exemple il s'est est insérée dans le
paysage qui un paysage rural les
adolescents monde y est mais madame
pause ça me faire de là je monte sur une
vache et après je mets quatre heures à
arriver n'importe où alors je m'en vais
pas et je m'en vais pas surtout parce
que je suis bien ici et pourquoi il
était bien ici parce qu'ils apprenaient
des métiers qu'ils apprenaient remis par
exemple les apprenants à travailler le
métal à travailler le bois à la cuisine
et sa ex très à la mode en ce moment la
cuisine d'ailleurs c'était les repas
étaient absolument délicieux ils
apprenaient pas mal de choses et est
donc pour moi ça a été un réconfort de
me dire donc ça peut exister et on m'a
expliqué que ça existait parce que c'est
éducateurs étaient un peu mieux payés un
peu mieux reconnu sans doute
et puis il avait réussi à faire insérer
tous le centre éducatif fermé qui était
assez mal vu au départ dans le tissu
rural alors livrer des repas à la maison
de retraite des chaises des bancs et des
tables à la mairie bon ben donc ça peut
arriver ça peut exister
voilà déjà je voudrais que ça dans le
rapport retrouverait ce souci
particulier des des gamins et de la
façon dont il traite ses guerlain qui
ont oui certes commis des actes de
délinquance sûrement grave puisqu'ils
sont là mais il n'empêche ensuite une
autre préoccupation est un autre sujet
de d'effarement pour moi a été la visite
des locaux de garde à vue dans les
commissariats et le premier où je suis
allé c'était
beaucourt 2020 c'était près de calais il
s'agissait d'un mobil-home un algeco
dans lesquelles les policiers créac'h et
des dents il est vachement froid et ils
nous ont accueilli avec bonheur les
polices et ils nous ont accueilli avec
bonheur parce qu'ils nous ont dit
regardez c'est honteux
et c'est vrai que c'est la première fois
que j'entrais là dedans vous peut-être
vous l'avez fait plusieurs fois je ne
sais pas mais chantre est dans une
espèce de cellules dont des geckos à
côté d'un micro-ondes destinée à
réchauffer les plats absolument immonde
le micro-ondes je veux dire chaprais
dans la cellule une odeur horrible m'a
prise à la gorge parce que la chasse
d'eau ne marchait pas il y avait trois
types là dedans on sa sieste sur le
matelas
on se demande ce qu'on va choper je vous
assure le co vide peut-être des punaises
de lit parce que c'est fréquent
également des puces j'en sais rien la
gale puisque c'est fréquent également et
surtout un ma stupéfaction
j'ai vu des vieilles couvertures tout
sale dégoûtante entassés et jeux d'eau
que j'ai demandé qu'est ce que c'était
que ses couvertures m'a dit c'est
couverture des gardés à vue cet e-mail
date de quand elles dataient de 15 jours
et elle se repasse deux gardés à vue a
gardé à vue
et ça je vous parle de décembre alors
que je pense que sincèrement en
descendre on n'en était pas du tout au
point où on en est aujourd'hui où on
nous demande encore de faire très
attention où on a encore nos masques où
on se jette pas les uns sur les autres
et je pense pas qu'on se passerait de
vieilles couvertures entre nous et je me
disais les trois quarts des gars qui
étaient là en en garde à vue était en
situation irrégulière les policiers nous
ont expliqué que certaines destinations
c'était pas la peine ils allaient rester
deux jours et puis m
ils allaient ressortir donc ils sont ces
gens soient ils sont nés au centre de
rétention
soit ils partent à la prison soit ils
sont remis dehors au milieu de nous tous
mais de toute façon j'estime que et je
pense que vous aussi vous comprendrez ce
ne sont pas des conditions d'hygiène
sanitaire tellement c'est très choquant
à voir et c'est très choquant a intégré
et depuis on a fait au contrôle général
on continue avec assiduité des visites
de commissariats et de cellules de garde
à vue pour constater que c'est
absolument partout la même chose à
savoir que ja c'est pas le cas en
gendarmerie
il ya partout un manque cruel de
désinfection des matelas entre chaque
garde à vue
et surtout d'écouter et je dirais aussi
et bien sûr des couvertures qui se
refilent elles sont pas nettoyés le
marché qui est conclu avec les
prestataires qui viennent nettoyer c'est
soit une fois par semaine soit une fois
tous les quinze jours soit parfois une
fois par mois c'est à dire mais il n'y a
aucun souci là dedans de 2,2
gestes-barrières de 2 à 2,2 quelque
chose de sané qui relève du des gestes
barrières et sanitaires de quoi vous
trouverez également dans ce rapport
notre étonnement aussi sur les centres
de rétention qui à un moment
bonjour se sont se sont vidés un peu
n'est ce pas beaucoup même
puis se sont remplies alors je sais
qu'il ya une partie partie des résidents
des centres de rétention qui vient
de prison mais une grande partie
également il constitué d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui n'ont commis
d'autres fautes que d'être sans papiers
et j'ai les quineurs et qui en ces temps
de covin ne repartent donc ta il
n'aurait pas certaines destinations a
parlé ce qu'on appelle les dubly n'est
que vous connaissez et qui font donc un
petit tour en europe et à part les
albanais qui repartent sans rechigner
puisque de toute façon ils reviennent je
vois pas quel est l'intérêt de les
retenir
d'autant que si tombé sur un rapport de
du sénat qui fait état d'un rapport de
la cour des comptes
laquelle je me suis jetée et qui estime
à 620 euros par jour le prix d'un jour
de retenue pour un retenu pas pour un
simple pour un retenu ce qui fait que
j'aime je me demandais je vous demande
est ce que vous pourriez vous interrogé
sur le sort de l'argent public dépensé
mais je ne sais pas pourquoi je
comprends bien le côté punitif qu'il y à
a gardé les sortants de prison au centre
de rétention 90 jours en plus de la
prison est ce que je dois comprendre que
le ce côté punitif s'applique également
aux étrangers sans papiers en situation
irrégulière enfin je trouve que le prix
à payer est un peu dure à gober ça une
bière c'est à double tranchant
on peut pas espérer que les couleurs ni
souhaitait jamais que la situation dans
les centres de rétention
soit moins bonnes parce qu'on y mettrait
moins d'argent parce que ce que j ai vu
également d'étranges par exemple ce que
j'appellerais le pavillon des positif à
vincennes
les cas qu'ovide soient les cas coville
soit l'écart contact avec un kobe dont
un centre spécial un plaisir mais le
pavillon des cas contacts j'ai rencontré
la cinquante personnes des hommes qui se
frôlent qu'ils touchent qui n'ont pas de
masque et qui n'ont pas accès aux jeunes
parce que nous at on dit le boivent où
ils y mettent le feu
pour se laver les mains il faut aller
chercher son savon dans sa chambre et
l'a portée au lavabo collectif et leur
apporter ensuite dans sa chambre enfin
tout ça n'est pas tellement de nature à
inciter aux gestes barrières je voulais
vous en prévenir et tout ça pour cette
modique somme donc de 620 euros jour qui
m'a littéralement scotché et je les lui
donc dans un rapport du sénat et je vous
dis je
et c'était marqué que ça venait d'un
rapport de la cour des comptes sur
lequel donc je suis je suis allé
vérifier que le chiffre était bien le
bon tellement ça m'a surprise ce qui
fait que si vous multipliez par 90 jours
et le nombre de retenus donc pour le
moment je connais pas on va arriver à
des sommes pourquoi je ne sais pas
hum ça c'est ça ma soucier et puis le
peu de cas qui est fait aussi des
l'accès aux soins dans les centres de
rétention
bon je pense que tous savent où sont des
sujets que vous connaissez et il ya des
centres plus ou moins viable je pense
plus ou moins agréable si je peux dire
sont moins confortable et certains le
sont et 7 à 9 féminisme pas du tout elle
a évidemment les hôpitaux psychiatriques
une loi a été votée
enfin là c'est pareil
elle a été glissé un amendement dans le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
ça n'a pas été déférée au conseil
constitutionnel n'empêche le conseil
constitutionnel s'en est emparé quand
même et là je peux vous dire où on en
est plutôt que de revenir sur l'année
2020 mais on en est à des discussions
avec le personnel des hôpitaux
psychiatriques qui qui nous ont fait
part et qui m'ont fait part à peine
j'avais pris mes fonctions puisque ça a
été un des grands thèmes d'adeline hazan
comme vous le savez je crois qu elle a
énormément travaillé sur les hôpitaux
psychiatriques je pense qu'elle les a à
peu près tous visités et elle a noué
avec les psychiatres et le personnel des
hôpitaux des relations que je souhaite
poursuivre bien sûr mais tous nous ont
fait part d'un souci que je suis pas
comme vous allez pouvoir le régler vous
aimez j'espère que vous allez les aider
la psychiatrie est actuellement dans une
crise que vous connaissez il ya une
fuite des psychiatres
effarante du service public il y en a de
moins en moins de psychiatres donc
l'article 84 qui a été adoptée les
inquiète énormément bon ça sera pour
l'année prochaine
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que eux la
fermeture des lits d'hôpitaux
psychiatriques devait être compensé par
de l'ambulatoire dehors il ne l'a pas
été et ce qui fait huer les hôpitaux que
j'ai visités j'ai lu ce qu'avait écrit
adeline hazan à ce propos c'est très
préoccupant parce que ça rejaillit sur
les malades
et comme vous le savez ce qui rejaillit
sur les malades fait que les soins sans
consentement augmente également et il ya
une espèce de vase communiquant avec les
prisons puisque comme vous le savez les
prisons joue un peu le rôle d asile
d'antan on estime à 30 % le nombre de
malades mentaux
assez assez atteint qui vivent en prison
or je ne pense pas que les surveillants
pénitentiaires soit l'infirmier
psychiatrique et je crois pas que au cam
nou pourrait supporter si on était soit
surveillants soient malades de vivre
dans ces conditions les malades avec une
paire au ventre une angoisse
certainement
et les surveillants pareil d'ailleurs
j'ai assisté en prison à l'agression
d'un surveillant par un dette du fou une
agression sauvage
le saurien c'était au quartier
d'isolement mais c'est rien a gardé par
l'oeilleton il a vu le détenu au fond et
puis s'est dit ça va il a ouvert la
porte et il s'est pris la bouilloire
plein d'eau bouillante en pleine figure
ça m'a profondément marqué et perturber
un je peux vous dire que ça m'a et et
d'ailleurs il y avait il ya une attitude
assez assez inattendue la part des
autres détenus qui entendait ce qui
s'est passé par heure par la porte qui
sont mis à hurler contre le détenu à
l'insulté en disant c'est des bons
surveillants qu'est ce t'as foutu
connard tu vas enfin je vous passe les
insultes
l'autre était complètement déchaîné un
calme à bhl crié je vous emmerde nous
formons et ça ça nous amène à la
surpopulation dans les prisons et je
pense qu'on n'en parlera à l'occasion de
de la loi sur la confiance destinée à
restaurer la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire
et si vous voulez me poser des questions
merci madame
alors nous sidère n'avoir pas été trop
longue des questions de la part perçue
heures sur le président mesdames la
contrôleur général devrait excusez moi
parce que j'ai fait une autre réunion
sur le budget du sénat donc chez
je suis arrivé en retard mais j'ai eu
l'occasion de lire pas tout le rapport
mais une bonne partie et je voulais
remarquer combien le travail était
sérieux même exhaustif venant de madame
adeline hazan et de vous-même pour
rendre compte des réalités très
concrètes
je dois dire que malheureusement un
certain nombre de nos collègues ne sont
pas là aujourd'hui parce que comme cela
sans doute déjà été dit nous sommes dans
une période un peu particulière qui
requiert que nous fassions attention
surtout après ce qui s'est passé
dimanche aux réalités électorales mais
je suis je tiens à souligner que aussi
bien dans le rapport écrit que dans ce
que vous avez dit on ne peut on ose se
doit de remarquer que votre rapport est
nourrie d'une de beaucoup de choses
concrètes et que finalement ça s'inscrit
bien dans la suite de l'expérience qui
est la vôtre antin en tant que
observatrice assidu de la réalité
judiciaire
je lis je veut l'interroger juste sur
une question que vous n'avez pas encore
abordé justement qu'est la surpopulation
parce que je lis dans vos propos que
vous avez vous même signé je lis j'ai
excusez moi de citer paradoxalement
cette année fut aussi celle de quelques
nouvelles encourageantes
d'ailleurs dans le rapport vous ne
manquez pas de souligner très souvent
les bonnes pratiques et je pense que
c'est une bonne chose parce que par
rapport au personnel pénitentiaire le
fait qu'on met en avant les bonnes
pratiques c'est bien face et c c'est un
discours qui est plutôt motivant donc je
relis paradoxalement cette année fut
aussi celle de quelques nouvelles
encourageantes
il y eut au des au printemps dernier ce
mouvement inédit de déflation carcéral
entrepris grâce à des ordonnances de
libération de prisonniers sortie de
prison surpeuplée à quelques semaines de
leur fan ben une opération sans
précédent est salutaire destine à éviter
une large contamination rendue possible
grâce à l'implication de juge
d'application des peines des services
pénitentiaires et ce sans déclencher de
réaction négative de l'opinion publique
preuve est donc faite qu'il est possible
de ramener le taux d'occupation des
prisons à leur capacité d'accueil
moi je me réjouis de ce qui s'est passé
qu'on n'avait pas recherché puisque
s'est défait de la pandémie
on s'est rendu compte qu'avec cinq mille
personnes en moins il n'y avait pas
d'insécurité en plus et que la
surpopulation n'était pas une nécessité
comme on cherche toujours à le dire or
depuis quelques mois
vous le savez c'est reparti à la hausse
et on ne réussit pas à expliquer a
réexpliqué que la peine c'est pas la
détention qu'il faut bien sûr que ce
soit en détention les personnes qui
doivent l'être c'est une nécessité
absolue mais que d'autres peuvent être
punis d'autres façons par d'autres
peines ou peuvent se réinsérer d'autres
façons par d'autres peines et je voulais
vous demander votre votre réaction
je sais qu'un juge un jour avait sommé
finalement de les prisons de ne pas
accueillir deux personnes au delà du
mais comment perçu comme en arriver à ce
que l'on l'on comprenne dans ce pays que
la surpopulation n'est pas une nécessité
que l'on peut très bien donner au séjour
en détention plus d'efficacité
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de
surpopulation qu'on peut développer des
peines alternatives plus
utile notamment pour des jeunes qui sont
là pour des durées trop trop limités
alors que massivement l'opinion publique
pense le contraire c'est à dire comment
on peut faire est ce que moi j'aimerais
bien justement que la loi sur la
confiance de la justice mais je ne suis
pas sûr que l'aï vraiment dans ce sens
elle à aller dans ce sens et que l'on
puisse en même temps persuader nos
concitoyens de cela et je pense que
l'éternel réponse qui consiste à dire on
va construire des prisons
supplémentaires n'est pas la réponse
parce que les prisons supplémentaires
sont immédiatement surpeuplé c'est pas
je pense qu'il serait bien mieux de
rénover des prisons vétustes
ça c'est tout à fait nécessaire donc je
voulais vous demander comment vous vivez
et qu'est ce que vous dites entre qu'en
tant que contrôleur général
quand vous avez écrit ce paragraphe qui
est serein qui est calme qui est
tranquille qui explique ce qui s'est
passé du fait de la pandémie
et quand vous voyez que ça augmente à
nouveau tout de suite comment vous
pensez que l'on peut mettre un terme à
cette surpopulation et comment pensez
vous que l'on puisse persuader nos
concitoyens que ce n'est pas la bonne
solution
naturellement il faudrait que quelques
politiques s'emploient aussi à faire
comprendre cela
là c'est pour c'est à nous de le faire
et il ya du boulot
excusez moi monsieur le président j'ai
peut-être été un peu long après
plusieurs d'autres questions mal merci
de me le prendre les questions oui merci
monsieur le président merci madame pour
votre présentation on voit toute votre
émotion quand vous nous parler de ces
lieux que vous avez visité
c'est vrai que nous en tant qu'élus
locaux nous avons bien évidemment
connaissance des salles de garde à vue
et de tout ça et depuis bien longtemps
puisque malheureusement ça ne date pas
ça ne date pas d'hier vous allez donc
visiter acef peut-être était celui de
savigny-sur-orge qui est un modèle du
genre
alors tant mieux ça veut dire qu'un
autre encore donc ça veut dire qu'il y
en a d'autres dans mon département il y
en a eu un qui ne fonctionnait pas du
tout parce que dans les selfs comme
ailleurs l'âme d'une entreprise c'est
son chef pour qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez une équipe pédagogique avec un
projet pédagogique pour les enfants qui
sont ici forcément ça marche
un petit peu mieux que quand ils sont
livrés à eux mêmes je suis d'ailleurs
très très troublé que dans dans
l'exemple que vous nous donniez on peut
être propulsé éducateurs ainsi à 100
sans autre forme de procès juste si je
puis dire et pour donc terminer mon mama
remarques donc la surpopulation
carcérale bien évidemment s'en émeut
nous avons sous couvert de ce que peut
dire monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
visitez bois d'arcy avec eux chez le
président du sénat n'y a pas bien
longtemps donc nous avons effectivement
vu cette surpopulation les prisons ont
été vidés pendant la pandémie donc on a
bien vu qu'il y avait les prisons
étaient vides et le nombre de deux
d'actes de délinquance a chuté
forcément puisque nous étions tous
confinés donc par définition personnes
personne ne sortait donc on peut dire
aussi que tous ces gens dehors n'ont pas
participé à l'augmentation des actes de
délinquance par contre les violences
elles ont été ailleurs pendant le même
temps elles vont était à l'intérieur des
maisons et des appartements
donc en ce qui concerne tout ce que vous
dites ch sur les locaux bien évidemment
il manque deux mois un manque de moyens
qui si nous dénonçons depuis depuis
longtemps nos moyens financiers de moyen
humain
pour ma part je suis ravi que vous en
preniez connaissance
maintenant puisque vous exercer cette
fonction de contrôleur général des lieux
de privation de liberté en ce qui
concerne les détenus qui ne devrait pas
être en prison puisque ce sont des
prisonniers psychiatrique là encore
c'est de longue date on sait que la
psychiatrie est une spécialité pour
laquelle il ya une vraiment une baisse
de démographie en particulier d'ailleurs
et la pédopsychiatrie et qu'il y à des
détenus qui sont d'abord des patients
mais vous avez parlé d'un coup de
journée le coup de journée en prison
quand même inférieur au coût de journée
en hôpital psychiatrique et quelquefois
on peut se demander si si c'est pas si
on ne se retrouve pas plutôt en prison
qu en hôpital psychiatrique voilà les
quelques remarques que je voulais vous
donner ma dame assise sur votre question
le contrôle le contrôleur général
liberté est d'abord un merci monsieur le
sénateur de votre question sur la
surpopulation
en fait je suis arrivé en en parlant et
en disant que que j'avais relu
nostalgiquement le formidable rapport
sénatorial de 2000 prison une
humiliation pour la république et que et
je me demandais comment vingt ans plus
tard on pouvait encore en être là et moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour aller
porter la bonne parole mais c'est aussi
à vous les élus mais je doute que ce
soit un sujet tellement porteur et
malheureusement je pense avec tristesse
qu qu'on va plutôt passé une année sur
ce sujet plutôt pénible jusqu'aux
élections je crois pas que ce soit le
sujet le plus porteur politiquement en
ce moment mais moi je me ferais le
relais quand même avec mon équipe
puis je ne suis pas seul mais il
faudrait faire comprendre oui que que la
seule punition n'est pas la prison et
que exécuté sa peine peut prendre
diverses formes travail d'intérêt
général les alternatives même les
amendes et je vais d'ailleurs me rendre
en allemagne parce que je suis très
curieuse de voir ce pays qui est quand
même qui nous ressemblent beaucoup qui
est notre voisin et qui a réussi à
diminuer et son taux d'incarcération
par le ratio n'est ce pas par habitant
et son taux de surpopulation qui est au
taquet fois qu'il n'a rien à voir avec
le nôtre y sont à 80 % d'occupation en
développant des alternatives voudrait
absolument savoir comment ils ont fait
eux-mêmes jeu puisque jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai lu des articles plutôt militants
des articles de journaux mais maintenant
je vais me rendre pour comprendre et si
vous voulez je vous enverrai une note
en tout cas je ferai une note parce que
je voudrais c'est quand même incroyable
pourquoi eux ils ont réussi les pannes
ou alors que je crois pas que ce soit un
pays particulièrement laxistes
l'allemagne et c'est un pays qui nous
ressemblent plus tôt et voilà je
j'aimerais bien savoir si leurs hommes
politiques leur ou disons les
responsables des prisons ont tenu ou les
magistrats ont tenu des discours qui ont
donné confiance à leurs populations
parce que nous pour le moment la
population française d'un guère
confiance dans et les magistrats
eux-mêmes disent c'est plus compliqué de
de développer une alternative que
d'envoyer en prison
il faut rendre ça plus fluide plus
facile c'est mais la france est un pays
curieux pour ça parce que c'est quand
même vingt ans plus de vingt ans je sais
pas combien de temps qu'on en parle
jeudi ce rapport du sénat mois il
m'avait énormément marqué il a
énormément marquée de monde et c'est
pour ça que j'ai très confiance dans et
sénateurs pour parce que je crois que
vous êtes moins soumis aux échéances
électorales à la pression et que et que
peut-être c'est pour ça que votre
travail est plus serein
enfin bon on attend beaucoup de vous
bien merci madame pas d'autres
observations particulier avez vous une
dernière question
ça c'est le rapport à l'activité 2020
avez vous une idée à la fin de l'année
mais lignes directrices sur les
contrôles que vous faites en 2021 est un
choix thématiques particulier vous
l'avez évoqué tout à leur communication
de l'enfance mais c'est votre seul choix
s'il est tel que celui là non je
voudrais qu'on mette le paquet ce soit
en prison ou dans les centres éducatifs
fermés sur l'éducation le travail c'est
à dire la réinsertion et je sais ça qui
me semble oui ça me taraude parce que je
dans les prisons et je pense qu'on en
parlait tout à l'heure il ya aucun ya un
accès met minable ce au travail ou à
part une prison qui est sans arrêt cité
en exemple mais il ya et je vous assure
j'ai j'ai tenu le le standard du
contrôle une journée et ça m'a appris
beaucoup et notamment juin un gamin oui
je suis un gamin de 19 ans s'est mis à
pleurer
ce qui me dit je te fais je dois passer
le bac et bien comme l'enseignement est
arrêté je j'ai le cned à la place de
l'enseignement par correspondance il dit
mais ça m'arrive le livret 5 mai arrivée
avant le 3 le 4 je ne les ai pas reçu le
1 je les reçus après le 6 et il éclate
en sanglots et une vie si j'ai pas le
bac après tous les efforts que je la
fais à cause de ça madame je vais mourir
et je me disais ma faim c'est trop bête
et ça ça rejoint l'internet en prison
par exemple on est assez rétrograde là
dessus pourquoi l'enseignement n'est-il
pas dispensés par internet alors que par
non mais les les détenus sont puni pour
ça mais il ya beaucoup de portables qui
circulent donc internet donc sais pas
pourquoi
on est frileux comme ça voilà alors moi
je suis oui c'est un des soucis il soit
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques pour
les enfants fermé et les adolescents
dans les centres éducatifs et dans les
dans les prisons je voudrais qu'on met
le paquet sur ce qui ce qui amène les
gens à pouvoir vivre de façon normale
c'est à dire apprendre un métier
apprendre quelque chose retirer quelque
chose de leur séjour dans ces lieux
d'enfermement
j'ajoute que il ya une énorme lacune et
je pense que vous y pensiez quand sur la
loi sur la protection de l'enfance une
énorme lacune à savoir que non seulement
les parcours des enfants depuis leur
plus tendre enfance
les enfants de la zone sont chaotiques
un foyer une maison d'accueil un jeu bon
mais en plus les différents lieux
d'accueil où ils ont été recueillis
perdre leur trace immédiatement par leur
départ il s'agira au centre éducatif
dont josé parler qui marchait si bien où
nous a fait part de ses regrets amers
en dix ans on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
deviennent hors même intelligemment même
pragmatiquement même ça me paraît la
moindre des choses même pour nous qu'est
ce qu'ils deviennent une autre question
dans l'activité qui est la vôtre les
déplacements sur site sont et de quelle
nature quotidien plusieurs fois par
semaine ça s'organise comme an par si
vous équipe qui a laissé vous allez à
toutes les visites
comment ça fonctionne et les équipes
pattes
les deux premières semaines de chaque
mois et moi je me débrouille pour partir
toujours la première semaine
d'accord voilà avec eux je souhaite
évidemment g g
j'aimerais partir quinze jours mais en
fait quand je reviens déjà au bout d'une
semaine
parfois j'ai été obligé de revenir même
dare-dare parce qu'il y avait une
urgence
je trouve une pile de trucs donc mais je
m'efforce y aller toujours la première
semaine
bien oui mais à mercier président vous
donnez vraiment beaucoup de mal je
voudrais savoir si les conclusions les
recommandations qui sont donnés par le
contrôleur général des lieux de
président de liberté sont suivies
si elle était suivie je serai pas la
joie je serai bien mais non c'est à dire
elles sont suivies g vous diront c'est
très gratifiant sur place on a des
discussions avec les équipes et on a des
retours notamment dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques avec une réflexion des
équipes etc et dans les centres
éducatifs fermés également alors c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué en prison mais
ce qui me frappe c'est que même en
prison au sillon on a des discussions
avec l'encadrement avec la direction
et vous voyez ça peut ça peut amener à
des changements ce qui me soucie moins
c'est ce qu'on envoie aux les
recommandations qu'on envoie aux
ministres et qui j'ai écrit dans dans
l'avant-propos nous reviennent j'ai
trouv avec son prix avec beaucoup de
désinvolture par exemple les bonnes
pratiques qu'on s'efforce de chaque fois
mettre en exergue comme ça mais elles
sont pas diffusés c'est dommage on y va
à leur place finalement et on relève des
choses qui pourraient être améliorés et
on dit regardez là comme c'est bien
regardez là comme ça va bien fait la
même chose mais c'est aussi c'était
poussière alors nous on les relève dans
nos rapports est d'ailleurs une chose
c'est qu'on aimerait bien que nos
rapports figure dans les bibliothèques
des endroits
quand visite notamment les prisons quand
même comme j'ai lu eux je découvre avec
étonnement écrivez vous tirer c'est un
euphémisme tirer la désinvolture avec
laquelle sont traités les
recommandations du contrôle général par
les ministres auxquels ils sont adressés
alors c'est grave quand même c'est quoi
lui ce la justice ministre de
l'intérieur ministre de la santé qui
traite vos recommandations avec
désinvolture
c'est quand même moi j'ai lu ça j'ai
coché parce que je ne comprends pas de
la part d'un ministre que que ce puisse
être ainsi mais j'espère que ça va
changer
mais vous savez le sentiment de recevoir
des réponses administratives
oui trop souvent mais je pense que là je
sais pas moi j'ai très bon espoir et
puis mes collègues au contrôle mondy
n'espère pas faire la révolution mais
dieu on change quand même sur place des
choses petit à petit on a des retours
positifs tient là ça a changé là ça a
changé
mais vous savez vous donner le sentiment
que les retours viennent des
établissements quand vous y allez plus
que des ministres oui et des discussions
qu'on a sur place avec je suis un peu
froid mais c'est peut-être tort non non
mais j'espère que les ministres vont en
tirer les conséquences
bah c'est mon espoir en avait parlé je
pense que vous les voyez les ministres
un peu j'aperçois un homme de la gontrie
c'est qu'elle dise rien quand même
pardon c'est sûr ce serait étonnant que
madame de la gontrie nous disent rien à
ceux ne sais pas ça m'étonnerait a très
bien alors vous avez la parole à ses
présidents
je salue dominique simonnot je voulais
savoir vous avez fait état tout à
l'heure de l'engagement de votre
prédécesseur dans le domaine de la
psychiatrie qu'elles sont quel est votre
projet votre programme pour l'année qui
vient
sur ce sujet là sur ces actions là où ça
je vais continuer ce café adeline hazan
parce qu' il n'est pas question de
s'arrêter là dessus ella ella l'a bâti
quelque chose elle a pesé de tout son
poids pour que pour que cette loi sur la
contention l' isolement pour arrive que
franchement elle a fait un travail
extraordinaire alors donc on va
continuer d'autant plus que grâce à elle
au sein du contrôle il ya vraiment des
spécialistes qui se sont formés à ça
donc n'est pas question d'arrêter
au contraire cela parce que j'ai dit que
une de mes priorités serait le travail
la réinsertion et l'apprentissage et
l'éducation dans les lits d'ems dans ces
lieux fermés que sont les prisons et les
centres éducatifs que je vais pour qu'on
va pour autant arrêter avec les hôpitaux
psychiatriques non pas question
ça ne vous rassure non mais c'est vrai
que notre attention avait été attirée
sur la situation dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques sur les situations
éventuellement on les décisions de
privation de liberté et des conditions
dans laquelle les gens été retenue
nous nous sommes rendus d'ailleurs avec
hamdi faut le coup au moins deux
reprises
on a eu un certain nombre d'explications
donc naturellement elles étaient toutes
valables mais non parce que s'est posé
quelques questions de fond qu'elle
attendait son moyen quoi vous avez vu
comme comme les équipes sont désespérés
comme les psychiatres sont j'ai même vu
un endroit où il n'avait plus de psy ils
ont manqué ils ont fait revenir un
médecin qui travaillait là avant et kate
à la retraite et non non repêché de là
pour assister les psychiatres et y
paient alors ce que dans mon équipe
isabelle des mercenaires qui se paient
18000 euros par mois pour remplacer le
psy enfin cesser complètement mais c'est
aberrant c'est aberrant
donc il faut il faudrait et ça le
ministre de la santé je crois en a
conscience qu'on a beaucoup parlé
justement et et il dit que oui c'est
vrai la filière fait fuir les gens c'est
qu'il faut réhabiliter cette filière le
rendre plus attrayante plus
enfin c'est idiot de pays peut-être
qu'il y aurait plein de mettre ça à
18000 euros qui viendrait dans sept ans
l'hôpital que j'ai vu et au lieu que de
prendre des gens qui sont qui sont là en
intérim qui reste trois mois donc c'est
pas pour le bénéfice de personnes a
constaté de difficultés
bien écouter s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions me contre un contrôleur il
nous reste à vous remercier de votre
venue cet après midi devant la
commission des lois du sénat et vous
souhaiter une bonne fin de journée
merci à vous
[Musique]